we got a rookie here in the same shot
this is great um what can you say your
new partners bringing to show enthusiasm
very enthusiastic it's true yeah no
she's a actually he brought a lot of
good energy to the show I think Thanks
that's all you got
[Laughter]
now how does it feel stepping onto this
set like these guys it's kind of about
knowing that these guys are a family
with like the Chicago PD's he'll go mad
in Chicago fire did you feel welcome to
immediately into the cold yeah everyone
what jesse was me no is there really it
wasn't really there all the really
lovely people it's a really good group
and so I came in you know a bit shy and
quiet I think the part like a day and
then and they were all very welcome
being in the film it was part of the
family I mean he's dead working on it
I'm gonna go now speaking of getting
dark we're getting really dark with with
Jay this season you know why is why is
now the right time to to work on this
PTSD to bring all those things out into
the light um it's a good question I
think I think Jay has really gone
through a lot especially with his
partner leaving at the end of last year
he hasn't had anybody to rely on and in
the first episode you know he kills his
little girl by accident and I think it
really opens a door and kind of eats
away them and it's it's interesting
after five years to see a character
change and transform a little bit and
you know to go down the dark side yeah
yeah coming in as his partner how do you
deal with that
I mean Haley's main thing is to protect
him even at times that he thinks he's
okay and he's got it under control to
protect him and look out for him and
tried to be there for up and that's kind
of her whole thing when he was going
through all that she was just there
ready to help now the senior shooting
today you guys it's it's really intense
there's a lot of action going on today
how do you come down off of a scene like
that is it is it just automatic are you
guys so easy it's switching back and
said being normal or just some of that
stick with you
oh it's been five years man I'm on
Twitter right away Twitter Instagram
just you know messed around horrible um
yeah I don't know I think that we all
and I think everyone gets on really well
together so even though the subject
matter is really heavy and a lot of
things going on Rinne I feel like most
of us when we yell cut can kind of step
away from that and then you got you know
like we're it's playing pretend you know
and we have fun it's only so many like
murder scenes are like dealing with a
rapist and interrogation or something
you can do until you gotta start you
know making light of everything
otherwise it's gonna really bring down
your day all right
of course not who would you say in your
life I guess I'm gonna put this who
would you say in your life actually bugs
you the most about spoilers for the show
spoilers for the show that asks about
spoilers yeah my mom my mom definitely
and I never tell her anything I won't
give her anything you drives her crazy
[Laughter]
who an eisley bugs me the most
I feel like my cousin's all three of my
cousins and in Winnipeg are like so what
could happen what happened next
sworn to secrecy so they've never been
able to suss anything out no you guys
are it's airtight
right no and sometimes like my mom will
ask questions like way out like what's
gonna happen with like Voight and ruzek
and all that somebody go well I don't
know I haven't read it so you know as
much as I do so with a hundred EPS one
coming up we're gonna see another
crossover episode with Chicago franchise
what's going on I don't I I actually
don't know anything you know I have not
seen a script yet I know there are
people that know but we are not the
people that know yes I do know this I
know that I think I'm in an episode of
Chicago if I'm in the fire episode for
the crossover that's all I know
do you get so that's cool do you get
extra excited when you see yourself in
an episode of another show does it feel
like special thing it's a fun day
because you get to go and hang out with
all your you know all your friends and
family on one of the other shows you
know it's a good like a party party so
it's exciting that I get to you know who
am I gonna get to work with that's
that's always exciting yet I know that
on the show you have actual police
officers like I've working background or
can I help you guys put stories together
how how important is it to you how much
weight do you guys put into doing right
by those guys it's of the utmost
importance
you know if we don't have the respect
and the the nod from the men and women
that we work with dinner actually police
officers then we're not doing a good job
yeah it's so the fact that they're here
and they're always bringing a level of
authenticity to it that helps the show
that's what the viewers love and it
helps us you know feel like we're really
doing something good something special
there's a lot of talk now police are
coming under a lot of scrutiny
you know Chicago especially isn't the
news quite a bit for what's happening on
the place was happening with you guys
are exploring that more in this season
can you speak to how that just change
the tone of the show and how you're how
you're treating the shona what I think
it's important to really do current
events and ripped from the headlines
topics and stuff like that it didn't
keeps the show current it keeps the fans
engaged you know so I'm freaking about
it in the news why shouldn't it be a
part of the universe here that we're
filming because it keeps it authentic
and it brings a real authenticity to the
show that we like playing as actors and
I think the faith the fans like seeing
and they can connect with that makes for
having television